this is rainy-day daydream and this what
really happens in this episode they just
sort of imagine stuff and that's about
it okay and it kind of comes to life and
it kind of tries to kill them and it
kind of makes no sense but that's
Adventure Time like it's it's good you
know what I I think I like the concept
more than even okay the execution is
good too but it just it's not for me if
that makes sense like okay the idea is
that first of all a knife storm happens
which i think is the most threatening
thing I've ever heard
just seeing all those knives come down
just like it just looks I just think of
that image is just unpleasant then we
see it's even more unpleasant Oh
beautiful at the same time yeah I love
the way it feels like it's so beautiful
it's anyway
so they obviously can't go outside so
Jake wants to use his imagination Finn
doesn't want to and Jason Mansion nation
starts to come to life well what I like
what's both good and bad about it is
that you don't see it and I like that
that's very different that it's it's
physical but it's all invisible yeah um
and I like bases imagine a steel
umbrella stopping all the knives from
coming down and they sort of stop you
know they just stop like there's
something there blocking it so I like
that I like that sort of forces you to
see it as well you know like Oh what
does it look like what could it be
they're about the same time you're sure
just looking at their tree house which
is something cuz usually I make the
argument why couldn't they just imagine
why couldn't they just said I got my
wish but at the same time I'm like yeah
what does it look like one of these
things uh you know what's their design
because I like the designs on this show
I've actually really grown to like the
these designs um but at the very end I
like how fin has to use his imagination
get the imagination machine back
I like his obsession with not having
prissy things in there and like every
time ones in there like something super
manly has to come in I think that's very
much like a boy brain um and he gets his
imagination back and it's about it so I
get the one element I really like
because you wouldn't expect it is that
Finn starts off not liking the idea of
using his imagination I think that's
actually very different because you
would just think oh well this kid has
had a lot of imagination I mean you see
all the stuff he does but then yeah when
you think about it's like he's not
imagining that stuff it's all that we
know of I still think it's all in his
head not seen elsewhere
I'm telling you yet I think it's all it
is that that's it's the apocalypse
happened this is his way of coping with
it
he's just going around seeing all this
stuff come making this magical world I
serve like his video games it just all
sounds like boy fancy to me but that
that's my supply which will make sense
why he can't use his imagination either
because he's already using his
imagination so it'd be difficult for him
he's like no I don't want to do that
thing where you imagine that you're
somewhere else cuz that's dumb even
though that's what he's doing so it
would make sense of that anyway rigueur
mmm it's not the idea that he would
still not want to use his imagination or
just find it boring I think is very
interesting um because it's such a left
turn but at the same time when you see
all the stuff he fights and does you can
guys see why just he's already doing
stuff that people imagine already so why
would he want to imagine anything else
um so I like that aspect I do like how
at the end he has to actually start
using it you know to create the machine
I like when the imagination is turned
off how boring Jake is I like he plays
one note like a violin like that was
great um so yeah it's good I'm not
saying it's bad I'm saying that I wish
it's the it's the impatient side of me
that's like you know come on I want to
see the monster
even though like that which is very
clever and that's actually sort of what
makes it kind of brilliant in a sense
that you're forced to imagine yourself
but it still still tries to be nice but
that's just that's a total just me
personal squirming thing so how about
you
personal squirming thing I don't know
looks like a disease a personal
squirming thing no for me um you know
having two kids when ice when they were
younger and they would do their whole
imagination thing and they'd be running
around the house doing their thing they
would just describe it I literally was
like the outsider like we were with Finn
and Jake we only got to see nothing
because we weren't the ones imagining it
we were just kind of watching them
imagining things and it's like watching
some kids just in your house doing the
exact same thing so for me it brings a
smile to my face because anytime I see
this episode I think of my kids and them
running around just doing and going
crazy with their imagination because you
got to think back when you are a kid
running around doing whatever imagining
things
your parents were like why and I like
how he has to constantly tech check with
Jake you know well what's in here is
this a1 can I go around can I it that
doesn't remind me when um yeah thinking
we've all played with kids you know just
like you know no it's a big giant blah
blah blah you have to sort of you know
have them translate what they're seeing
we which is part of the fun you know
because it's like well what's the rules
to this thing out yeah if he did it how
do and yeah so so that's that's a lot of
fun yeah no I know it's it's it is good
it is actually good it's just like I
said it's I I think it's because I'm so
used to see so many incredible images on
this show just like you know oh and the
one about imagination you don't see
anything that's hilarious
just I respect him more than I like it
if that makes sense
so and I think it is good to have an
episode that's actually much more sort
of restrain this sense why is the
imagination actually coming alive yes
serve is um but but yeah in terms of
what you see is very restrained and that
it's good to have enough
so like that every once in a while so
what did you think of the kind of first
full-on introduction of BMO well
technically the last episode was I'm
saying like he actually spoke more sorry
she spoke a bit more I didn't even know
yeah I actually I didn't know what
gender BMO was it's still kind of up in
the air yes and no sometimes they say
she sometimes they say he and sometimes
they say it so that that thing must have
quite an identity Christ
oh yeah well what do you finally think
of know that BMO is up and about nothing
terrible in Spanish because you have to
either say el BMO or love you mo Beauty
ma when everything was feminine um but
regardless
um what I think oh I like ya cuz you
sort of saw humor if we saw him with a
face before II flee yeah but yeah you
never really heard it talked and it
sounds like it has some sort of accent
but I can't quite I can't quite get it
but I'm just BMO even therefore more BMO
it is there much more crazy be most
awesome okay yeah no I would say right
now it just sort of seems like you know
this little thing it just says like you
know play me your here's a fun little
song here's something but no I like I
like the idea that I like the idea that
a videogame system is alive that just
sort of thing cuz everyone oh it's like
so we go video games are bad it don't do
it don't yeah yeah bad for kids and
everything and dice have shown there
have been some good things like you know
building your own city and you know
problem-solving and stuff like that
you're saying um but okay well I point
this way I'm not gonna say like video
games are like necessarily great you
know it turns of like you know yeah just
keep your kid inside the whole day and
do nothing but play this but you know
there's there's a mix and I think it
does get a little tiring when so I don't
know they're all bad all video games are
bad it's like I like that you know
you're in moderation they're fine you
know and I like the idea of taking this
video game console it's like you know
hey it's just you know it's a character
because you never see that so it's like
the games they play you know have the
characters where I like that it is
actually
character and lie and they're friends
with him they get along with ants I
don't know I guess I see so much anti
video game stuff and kid shows
ironically you think they'd be more Pro
or you get the very bad video game
that's video game system that's alive
like in Captain n where do you have Game
Boy which was yeah well I mean well that
whole show
yeah that that didn't cow because that
whole thing was a commercial and that's
I'm talking about shows that actually
try so yeah so I like that I like
something that's taking I don't say it
stands but sir this outlook that you
know not all video games are terrible
and they you know you can be friends
with your video games it's not like you
know hey you remember how all the
grown-ups are saying video games are bad
and stuff well remember it is it no in
moderation it's fine in my opinion so
last thing I'd like to say is one thing
I do truly love about this show and it
happens almost every episode is the one
with the why-wolves
finn gets his left sleeve ripped and his
backpack gets cut and all that stuff for
the rest of the episode his sleeve is
still red you know I did notice that
here yeah but he had certain rips
leavers so when he was getting beaten up
in dungeon his shoe flies off and his
bruises and stuff are still there and he
still is missing a shoe it's his nice
little touches again where it's a small
tiny amount of continuity that like a
lot of other shows just kind of ignore
like magically the next scene
everything's repaired and Nelson they're
all healed up like every time you saw a
window shot in this episode there were
still knives falling like they could
have completely ignored it and said you
know what no one's gonna even notice we
have the knives outside the windows or
not even though tree-trunks shows up in
an episode a but that's the way they I
already brought up two continuity errors
yeah oh yeah I know you're talking about
where they're actually making the effort
yeah I always liked it in um though I
mean every Maj has this different style
but something it sounds strange but I
always think is really cool is when I
look at a show or a movie whatever it
when I could see the wrinkles in the
clothes the things really need it's like
okay they're going the extra mile
you know there'd actually like you know
just have the little wrinkles and the
clothes and it sounds strange by this
sort of like you know how I serve at the
details like how many wrinkles are there
like when someone goes like this how my
wrinkles are in there sure dude yeah
stuff like that so I don't think it's a
yeah I don't think it's a bad thing
necessarily you know look at in terms of
appreciating it oh I think it's great I
think it's cool one like when normal if
you look at the characters they're very
smooth but you've brought up before when
Finn was being almost held underwater
and Olson you saw like every wrinkle and
everything like groove like when
Marceline turns into like the wolf wolf
bat creature yeah like every detail is
brought out and I think that's great
when it's that huge contrast between
super detailed and no details at all it
is funny you know they do the same thing
over and stimpy one they want something
to look in one they want seem to look
intimidating or intense they add more
detail to it they add more wrinkles that
is interesting because you think wow the
more realistic it is the more scary
isn't that fascinating interesting
commentary on life what have you done I
don't know
do your Segway come on you gotta have
something
what damn by